Meanwhile, with all the news
about shifting mask guidelines,
it's time to play the game
that's sweeping the nation...
♪♪
[ Applause ]
This is the game where we pick
a random audience member
and guess if there's a stache
[ Laughter and applause ]
under their mask.
So please welcome tonight's
audience member, Kevin Sproul.
Kevin, where are you?
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Nice to see you, Kevin.
Kevin, thank you for being
on "The Tonight Show."
Kevin, where are you from?
-San Diego.
That's all I can ask you.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, now, we have
to figure out if you've got
a stache under that mask.
Wait, hold on.
Quest, you go first.
You can ask him one question
and then you must
make your guess.
-Alright.
-Think hard.
You only get one.
-I got one.
-Okay. Kevin. Okay.
-Okay, so, at dinner,
how many napkins
are you likely to use?
[ Laughter ]
I'm actually an exceptionally
clean eater,
so I usually
only use one napkin.
-Mm.
Tricky.
[ Murmuring ]
[ Laughter ]
Mm.
-Are you going to guess now?
Or are you going to save it?
-Oh, okay.
I'll guess now.
I think he has a stache.
I think he's trying to trap me.
-Okay. Okay.
He said one napkin. Okay.
Higgins, your turn.
What's your question?
-Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-San Diego, again?
-San Diego.
-San Diego, California?
-Indeed.
[ Laughter ]
-Got it.
That's my question.
-That almost counts
as a question.
That can't be your question.
Is San Diego in California
is the question.
-Is it in California?
[ Laughter ]
Does it take you, now,
the same amount of time
as it always has to shave?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Pff!
I'm going to say
no stache.
-Yeah!
-Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Okay. My turn.
-It's in California.
-Thank you.
No, that's not my question.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Okay.
San Diego.
You look like
a clean-cut dude to me.
Alright, here's my question.
Do people mistake you for
Burt Reynolds
or Timothée Chalamet?
[ Laughter ]
-I would say the most I get is
the Buddha.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah!
-Buddha was cleanshaven.
Buddha is cleanshaven,
is what I think.
You say no stache.
-I say no stache.
-Quest?
-I say stache.
-You say stache.
-Yes.
-Gosh! I'm getting this vibe
of no stache.
I think he's a clean-cut dude.
I think no stache.
It's time to find out...
-...is there a stache
under that mask?
[ Drumroll ]
-Ah!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh.
That's not bad. Thank you, man.
I appreciate it.
Oh, wait, Kevin!
I'm sorry.
Thank you for playing.
Of course, here,
you've won a two-week supply
of Turtle Wax.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There you go.
-Turtle Wax.
When you're here, you're family.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for playing, bud.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Wow!
Stache.
[ Rimshot ]
-He knew. He knew.
-Yeah, looks good,
looks good, looks good.